the Joe Rogan experience you don't
really buy into the simulation do you me
[ __ ] no not long but I don't buy like
what this same person was saying to me
that there are atheists and they that's
fine you're allowed to believe that but
you you also have to accept it there's
possibly that's not true yes and they're
like that's what I believe and but then
they went on to say that they believe in
demons and I was like I don't know you
got it I think my you know that my
rationale about all this stuff is it
it's it's simple I was talking about to
my stepdaughter who's so smart so sweet
and really changed my life in a lot of
ways and we were swimming in the pool
talking about life you know and it's one
of these conversations it's like she's
like what do you think that there's a
God does she ask me and I said well we
don't go to church or anything and I
said I said I don't know but I think
this is something interesting to think
about I was like whenever I think about
that I try to think about the end of the
universe at the very end like the edge
and I can't picture it as I can I can't
picture as I guess I can tonight I can't
picture like infinity you know I can't
grasp that at all and I said the mere
fact that we can't grasp infinity will
lead someone like maybe Elon to believe
that we're there's a purposely that was
left off in some sort of simulation or
whatever but maybe that's would be the
argument I think that that the fact that
I can't picture maybe I'm just an idiot
but it makes it that I think that
there's maybe something more there's
definitely something more to it that
possibilities way open but I do think
what do you think I had this
conversation with a guy who was actually
an expert on it it's got Nick Bostrom
and he was trying to explain to me that
because the probability it's more likely
or very likely that we're in a
simulation because the probability of
someone eventually creating it and that
it's very possible that we're in it
right now
more probable than not put them what is
that I mean there I don't know a
simulation has to be a simulation that
why would it's why a simulation of what
from what well here's something I know
for sure okay
this is what I know for sure this is by
by my own experiences that we are the
only people on this planet that have
ever gotten to 2019 this is where we are
we know there's a history behind us mmm
we know that this is the peak we're at
2000 you in at a freaky time a man we're
at the tooth we're at 2019 right now if
we are we know we exist
we know we have culture we know we have
incredible technology we don't have any
idea for the only ones it's likely that
there's other life-forms out there it's
likely there's other intelligent life
out there but there might not be it
might be that this is a crazy situation
that happens incredibly rarely where you
have a planet that's this close to the
Sun where these life-forms figure out
how to [ __ ] with matter in an incredible
way and they start flying and sending
things through the air that videos and
instantly get to your phone this might
not ever happen this might only happen
here it might happen here and in
versions of here which if you believe in
infinity you have to believe there's
infinite versions of this so there's
infinite versions of life so it's almost
built-in mathematically that there's so
infinity is so big there's so many
possibilities that everything that you
have ever recorded has also been
recorded by you in another place with
infinite variations of each individual
song infinite variations of each album
that there's infinite versions and that
infinite versions of each version and so
that's insane the whole thing's
impossible for our little ant brains to
wrap around it that's possible too it's
not it's you know it's unlikely it's a
simulation I mean it's possible it's a
simulation but it's also possible that
this is as far as anything's ever gotten
because we're wheels as far as we've
ever got Pat and I are starting an
intergalactic publishing company yeah
we've signed futures we have future
rights cytology signed you to some
universe contract for like a billion
years isn't that like part of the deal
think with your on the Sea Org it's like
a billionaire service yeah I think it's
a billion years and think it's for the
whole universe you can't even work
another planets I think that you know
that it's interesting to think about
whenever you talk about something that
you don't know the answer to that the
simulation or this sure I mean your
dimensions and stuff I I think it's all
fascinating it's all possible man no but
I do think when it comes down to it like
a part part of the thing that causes
anxiety it is it is it's it's part of it
it's like accepting that something is
real you know
yes like there's some times when you're
having a panic attack or something like
it's just even [ __ ] happening this is
even [ __ ] real and and I think and I
think being in the moment as much as
possible when I really truly feel like
I'm living in the present I really feel
like you can really feel how special
life is yes and how if I was a
billionaire and I married the same trick
twice I would think I was living in a
[ __ ] simulation - that's what I think
about you on there's like this really
[ __ ] smart but he's a billionaire and
he married the same chick twice dude you
could marry anybody you wanted they gave
it a chance I don't know they gave it
one more chance he might be living in a
simulation well he might be interfacing
with a different dimension than us now
he might be I think about all the
different she's invented you know my my
stepdaughter went to his school for a
while Oh
ad astra it was a really amazing
experience for her I believe yeah
whatever schools raised that dude where
what is that Astra what is that it's a
school he has forgets his own school for
some of his children for some of the
employees of of his companies really oh
he got his own school oh holy [ __ ] I
just don't understand how that's all
possible how can you dig tunnels under
la make batteries make solar-powered
electric cars make rockets shoot them in
the space plan to colonize Mars yeah and
then marry the same chick twice that's
why he did it
time to find a new check I think it
might as much what might prove that he's
a genius just that maybe he gave me a
shot he gave it a shot with what if he
married her twice and worked out amazing
like the second time it's worked out
really amazing then like a thousand
different dimensions both marriages he
did it he did it because he needed it
the work out in the other dimension I'll
create random possibility yeah for no
reason just create random possibilities
in every direction
[Applause]